so I'm from Connecticut I'm 26 I'm a
grandmaster and I learned to play while
I was living in Argentina so that's
that's it that's all my that's all it's
relevant to me I guess but okay so
tonight I wanted to look at a game that
it's one of my favorite games of mine to
look at because it's one of my worst
games but one of the interesting things
about it is that it kind of showed me
what I need to look for in games I lose
because it was it was a it was a
devastating game for me because it was a
world junior championship game and I got
completely crushed so after it happened
I was like a suppressed memory I didn't
look at it for I didn't I didn't
acknowledge that it ever happened and
then I started analyzing it and I
literally I was like wow I really did
everything wrong in this game so I I was
able to target eventually I was able to
target these these like deep conceptual
mistakes that I was making and it helped
me just look even further back at games
that I had played and I started to
realize I had been making the same
mistakes for a long time so so I was
white she just said this up before I
guess so I was white and I was playing
to my defense against a very strong
player he's like 27 20 or something now
it was a ukrainian grandmaster named
yuri krivonishenko
and he decided to play an opening we
were talking about earlier called the
special akov a lot of you probably know
this opening it's very popular and very
dynamic
hence very tricky and here we go
he five and I you like to play the
Kalashnikov which is a similar idea
except you're including these two night
moves and I guess the biggest difference
would be that white doesn't have that
option of moving the pawn to c4 so yeah
so you're narrowing down a little bit
White's options so after d6 the bishop
comes to g5 I know I think you're an
advocate for this move and now you
really have to chase the night away
unlike the Kalashnikov where you can
kind of just leave this knight roaming
about b5 if if you're not careful so you
play a move like h6 then why it's just
going to take this night and you can't
recapture with the Queen because of
Knight c7 so and you can't really play
Bishop d7 yet because I can still take
this night and you can't take with the
bishop because now this pawn is hanging
so after Knight takes c6 you have
problems and if you have to do this that
just doesn't look very nice yeah yeah
but usually this Bishop is going on this
side and you're preparing f5 I don't
think it works out so well with the
bishop on e7 a usually you've already
kicked the knight back and since there's
no pressure on d6 you can just move the
bishop the other way
but unfortunately my opponent was well
aware of these subtleties and proceeded
to kick me kick my Knights back so I
definitely have to do something
immediately because black is threatening
to fork my Knights with before and even
if he wasn't threatening to do that this
Knight is horrendously placed I mean
it's just at the side of the board and I
know it sounds optimistic but usually
white is a
to reroute this night all the way to d5
and get a pretty decent position so
that's what I try to do but first I need
to free up the c3 square for the pawn
that way then I can actually move so
should be seven I got rid of the
defender of d5 that way if my knight is
uncontested for now
and c3 so Bishop g5 Knight c2 so it
looks like things are going according to
plan for me I'm I'm going to be able to
bring my knight and support the other
night on the d5 square especially now
after my opponent played ninety seven
trying to get rid of this guy I should
be able to either through Knight e3 or
night before maintain a knight on d5 so
here is it's where I made my first
mistake I played this move h4 and just a
little while ago I was talking about the
importance of not just treating openings
like an isolated part of the game which
is a mistake that I was making on a
daily basis when I played this game in
2006 I would say okay today I'm just
gonna study openings and I would sit
down and just memorize theory and after
move 15 I'd be like openings over I'm
gonna go watch TV you know and just have
openings and games all in their separate
categories and just treat them as
unrelated subjects this is very
dangerous because you're missing out on
the rest of the game because an opening
well theory is is a portion of a chess
game that actually has
and that's what theory is someone either
published their game or published some
analysis and you're just paying
attention to the first few moves
so theory might say okay and after H for
white is better and if you take that at
face value you don't really know what's
gonna you know where the piece is gonna
go what are the subtleties and this is
exactly what happened to me here
h4 was the main line it had been played
by Anand and that was good enough for me
I'm like well if I'm not played it then
I'm gonna play it but after Bishop h6 I
wasn't really sure what the idea of h4
was and I at that point I wasn't even
ready to ask myself that question I just
knew it was theory so it had to be right
and this is a move that I really don't
like just looking at the position
because this pawn is going to be very
weak and I'm not going to be able to
play normal moves like Bishop e2 and
castles because I'm always gonna have to
worry about this Queen taking my pawn so
in hindsight and I have played this
position again and night before is a
much more reasonable move with the very
simple idea that if Knight takes d5 I
just play Knight takes d5 and I'm still
in good shape
so here okay so a five I might be able
to throw in this Intermezzo move Bishop
takes pawn with check and even if I
wasn't able to do that I could probably
unload here on e7 and then when you take
back just bring the other night in but I
think just this Bishop takes pawn it's
it's too big of a problem right now
and it seems like an odd square to
choose to put the knight because most
people would just think well you bring
the knight to the center first but this
actually allows black a very interesting
option which is to take this Knight and
obviously you don't want to take with
the pawn and get the whole pawns in the
center so you take back with the knight
and already this this is kind of like
going backwards because we the whole
point is we want to keep the knight on
d5 and now actually the knight has been
forced back so now black just plays
Bishop b7 and threatens the pawn on e4
and the knight can't go back to d5 so
comfortably because there's too many
pieces threatening it and as we'll see
in the game white really wants to avoid
any kind of pawn structure where this
pawn on d6 is blocked because the only
way we can take advantage of this weak
d6 pawn is if we keep the D file open
because ideally we would want to set up
a battery of rooks and queens that's
going to put pressure on d6 and if we're
forced to put upon d5 you can forget
about it
we're never gonna get to this pawn again
so for that reason most people choose to
bring the knight out this way because
now there's there's no there's no way of
getting this knight out of d5 so I
played h4 and after Bishop h6 I played
a4 first
black took B takes a four and now I play
night before and maybe you'll notice how
I'm mixing all of these ideas I'm kind
of throwing in H four I'm throwing in a
four and I'm throwing a night before
when in fact I should have just been
playing night before right away but
again I was being a victim of one of the
the big dangers of memorizing theory and
that's that you're not really reasoning
over the board you're just trying to
replay something that you already saw
and sometimes that's going to confuse
you and you're gonna start mixing things
that you've already memorized so I was
all over the place already fortunately
my position isn't isn't terrible yet so
after castles I play Queen takes pawn
and after a five I develop my last piece
with Bishop b5 just taking advantage of
the fact that this pawn on a5 is pinned
because the rook on the 8th is hanging
so I don't really have to worry about
black taking my knight yet and now after
Knight takes d5 came the moment that
when I look at this game it's just
painful for me to watch what I did I
played it takes d5 this is a huge
positional mistake and it's very simple
to understand because after Knight takes
d5 which is the correct move
I'm not immediately putting pressure on
d6 but I'm always reserving the right to
do so later because there is nothing
saying nothing to say it's going to stop
me from playing maybe a move like rook
t1 and then moving my knight away and
then putting pressure on these six I
retained that my position retains its
potential to me very annoying
unfortunately since pawns can't move
back after etags d5 this transforms the
position permanently there is nothing
that's going to change this pawn
structure unless you know something
ridiculous happens like he plays Bishop
e6 then yeah I would get pressure again
but the likelihood of that happening
isn't very high I the only thing that
that I had seen was that after pawn
takes I would get a very strong square
in c6 so I would be able to put a piece
there but when I mean I don't want to
over generalize but unless there's
something really clear making a bad
decision about pawns is much worse than
making a bad decision about a piece
because you can always correct you know
a bad bleep placed piece
it's very hard to correct a badly placed
pond so II takes d5 was a very big
mistake and it was a huge learning
experience for me because this is such a
typical pawn structure that you see in
almost every Sicilian whether it's a
night or a Lowenthal at kalashnikov
Bullock slaps key black a lot of times
assumes the week d6 pawn and the only
way to really take advantage of it is to
avoid putting a pawn on d5 so this was
actually the last time I ever took on d5
with a pawn unless it was obviously
winning so like I said the correct move
would have been Knight takes d5 and
after Bishop e6 anyone said like what
should white do should I just Castle I'm
not saying there's like a win for white
so don't look for something spectacular
but just huh
yeah Rick do you want looks very
reasonable either rook d1 or move like
Bishop c6 or Bishop c4 they all have the
same basic idea which is to anticipate a
capture on d5 and avoid having to take
with the pond so yeah Rick d1 looks very
reasonable there are still some problems
for white like this pawn the reason I
can't really castle yet is because this
guy's hanging so I'm probably gonna have
to do something
weakening like g3 and black is probably
already a little bit better here but my
pieces are okay after he takes d5 not so
much so black plays f5 one of the big
advantages now that white has
surrendered some of his control over the
center is that the black pawns can start
rolling and after knight c6
when you have six I realized I can't
castle and I don't really have pressure
against these six so there's not that
much I can do
so I played this move before which has
its ID I mean I just want to take a pond
and try to get it as far above the board
as possible but it's usually not a very
sensible idea to start looking for
complications when your king is in the
center of the board so here my opponent
just played me for opening up the
diagonal for the Queen and now black is
threatening to take on c3 which is very
serious threat and a threat which I
totally ignored I should have just
defended this pawn with maybe Queen c2
and instead I took on a5 Queen takes c3
king of one I figured well since I'm not
going to be able to castle anyway
because my pawn is hanging on h4 I might
as well just get this pawn on e5 which
looks kind of threatening but isn't
really and I don't really care that I
have to move my King because I wasn't
able to castle before anyway and now I
was hoping that my opponent will allow
me to play move like rook h3 and once I
swing my work around I kind of fake
castled and solved my problem after king
f1 however my opponent is not gonna let
me play rook h3 and you played III here
which is a very strong move and the
problem now is that if I take this pawn
what does black do
does he take back here immediately
he has a much stronger move than taking
on e3 and it's based again on opening
lines against this king yeah so f4 and
I'm very close to getting checkmate in
here so if white plays a takes f4 simply
rook takes f4 it's going to win at least
a queen
and if white wants to keep the position
closed with efore then just f3 and i
haven't really solved the problem so
against III I played queen a3 hoping
that I would get to Trey Queens which
would greatly relieve some of the
pressure but all black has to do is just
avoid the trade so it just goes as far
away as possible so try to keep the
position close with f3 hopefully my king
will be able to blockade a little bit
but even then yeah I mean maybe if I can
get King e2 things won't be so bad
so after rook e8 King e2 and now Queen
g6 and the focus shifts over to G 2 so
the positions totally lost by now
because I can't stop all the black
pieces from just entering the game
especially this Queen takes G suit g2 is
particularly unpleasant and also once he
gets to play off for that Queen might
come to c2 as well so there's trouble
everywhere so Brooke g1 and now Queen g3
threatening queen f to know this wrote a
tough one defending is the threat and
just black finishes developing with
Bishop d7 I went on a few more moves
here with the Queen a4 was it Fischer
before yeah 94 Bishop takes b5 Queen
takes but it was a bishop takes yeah
and rook AC 8 and I think I could have
easily resigned here
I'm not down any material but I can
hardly move I mean my rooks have no
squares and they're totally defensive
positions and this a 6 a 7 8 idea is way
too slow and as well see like here what
what happened oh he went this room
so 94 v8 knight c6 and if you I finally
got the piece to c6 which was the whole
point of ETA d5
but unfortunately the damage is already
done so
rook b2 b3 and now Queen takes h4 my
opponent's not really interested in
capturing my pawn what he is interested
in is bringing the Queen back to have
six and then targeting the white came in
so four gauge one check
see four we know six and one last chance
to try to trade Queens but of course
after Queen f7 I just resigned there's
no way to prevent rook takes Knight
that's not gonna lose all of my pieces
so yeah I don't I don't see anything
really because this King can hardly move
so I wanted to follow up this game kind
of use this game as it preamble to
something I I learned because you know
it wouldn't be a good story if I just
show you another game where I got
crushed the same way which fortunately
hasn't happened yet
and but the what I like about the
special acog is that it's such a popular
opening and it's so rich in in
positional ideas as well as dynamic
because I made a positional mistake that
led to some really dynamic consequences
which means I just got attacked and
crushed eventually but it wasn't
immediately obvious that that was going
to happen when I played he takes d5 so
this makes it a very good opening to
highlight what the consequences of a
positional mistake can be without really
having to go over a game that's 150
moves long all right now I wanted to
show a game that I was playing the black
side was especially calm and this was a
period where I was a basically living in
Brazil for about a year because I was
playing a lot of tournaments in South
America and Brazil is just a really
great place to be playing chess or at
least it was back in 2007 when I was
there so after the first few moves are
going to be the same
and the reason I started playing this
opening with black was that that game
that I just showed you that I lost was
such a vicious beat down that I thought
this this variation was just amazing for
black and nobody knew about it there was
like the best kept secret around so I
said well if I'm gonna lose with white I
might as well be winning with black like
because you can't have both like you
can't be losing with both colors well
you can but that would just doesn't just
be sad so so I figured also playing it
with black because the problem was I
kept studying this is opening and I
would just focus on the first like 20
moves and I'd be like I just can't crack
it I don't understand what's wrong here
so I said okay this is what I'm gonna do
since I can't figure this out on my own
I'm just gonna start playing it with
black and I'm probably gonna start
losing a ton of games with black and
then I'll realize you know the way like
because however someone plays against me
that's what I'll just do with white the
problem was when I start playing with
black I just started winning every game
so so I was saying well that's nice but
I still can't figure out what to do with
white so I just started playing
something totally different with white
until you know until I could figure it
out but uh so c3
it's see-through in 97 this is this is
the the move from last game because this
is not actually the main move in the
special economy move is just to play I
believe it's just castles and then
Bishop e6 and black just tries to play
g6 and f5 so this is kind of an offbeat
move so my opponent played night before
so he knew what he was doing
unfortunately here he played this queen
h5 moon which is really ugly what he
should have done is played similar to
how I play the previous game excluding
this horrendous h4 move so after it
takes Queen takes and against a five
white it can choose to play Bishop b5
like I did previously you can take and
play Knight d5 but the point is that now
after I move my bishop out say what this
should be five with white I can just
castle the next move and I don't have to
be worried about this part H for being
hanging this Queen h5 move that my
opponent played is counterintuitive at
best because like I said in the main
line blacks idea is usually to play g6
and a5 anyway and now that's going to be
even stronger because after I play g6
it's gonna be with a tempo over this
Queen on h5 of course first i mean i
can't play g6 right away because the
bishop is hanging so Knight takes d5 and
now of course he takes d5 is the best
move right ya know so Knight takes
and now I just play g6 so queen d1 for
lack of a better move I mean you can't
go here here anyway f3 doesn't really
make that much sense so Queen d1 and f5
and already I think black has the better
position because even though white was
able to maintain the knight on I'm sorry
these pawns are still on the board able
to maintain the knight on d5 black got a
nice lead in development and already is
threatening to open up the position and
has the bishop pair which definitely
counts for something in this position
so after f5 Bishop d3 and Bishop e6 so
do you think when I play Bishop e6 am I
just developing a piece or do I actually
want to take on d5 that's it that's
that's all I'm trying to do actually
it's that simple I just want to change
the pawn structure and get a better pawn
structure than my opponent exactly I'm
not worried about opposite color bishops
being draw because that's not for a long
time
that's only in an endgame in the middle
game it's actually going to help my
winning chances and like you said if if
I get this position these pawns are
going to start rolling and I'm going to
get some very nice attacking chances
usually this Bishop gets rerouted to e5
and now this Queen can come to h4 and
after a move like maybe work a e8 and f4
all of blacks pieces are set up very
nicely for an attack so I'm definitely
threatening threatening to take on d5 so
my opponent played Bishop c2 so now if I
take it just takes back with the Queen
so I want King h8
castles and now I've played a move
similar to the one in your game I played
f4 so by now I realized that my opponent
he's not gonna let me take on d5 the way
I like he's not gonna let me put his
pawn on d5 and I'm not sure I really
want to take on e4 because this is just
gonna strengthen White's control over
like squares and I'm actually just
improving the position of this bishop
the bishop on c2 is much less active
than on e4 and here white might actually
be better now because after move like
Queen e2 and rook 81 the virtues of
keeping the knight on d5 are gonna start
becoming way more obvious so the idea of
f4 is simply to gain some space on the
Kings side and eventually get this
Bishop out of the way and start playing
moves like g5 and g4 and get an attack
going so that's three now I want to play
g5 but how can I do that effectively
this is gonna help us find my next my
next move here the first question what
do I need to move this pawn what's the
first thing I need to do yeah I mean
this pawn isn't going anywhere as long
as it's bishop on g5 that begs the
question where am I gonna put that
bishop I don't have to move it but
what's a what's gonna be a good Square
for it because I mean this is a square
but is it a good square I mean I might I
might want to move the H pawn later on
and I'm gonna have the same problem so I
want to start thinking about these
things now so they can put the bishop in
a square that's not gonna it's not gonna
hinder my play later on
okay but this is also might lead to some
problems later on because I might want
to put my queen on h4 and I might
actually be blocking the H file because
if I do something like this sometimes I
might want to put a rock on h6 and a
queen n h5 or something like that and
even after I played g5 I'm always gonna
have to be careful about some some g3 s
that are floating in the air where I
might be losing a piece that's that's
not happening here but it could usually
this Bishop is perfectly placed on d8
because if this bishop gets to d8 it's
definitely not going to interfere with
anything I'm doing on the kingside but
it's also gonna dominate the knight on
d5 because whenever you put the Bishop
two squares away from the knight you
know that that Knight can't move on in
the direction of the Bishop at least not
by themselves so that just means that
these five squares are controlled by the
bishop so this Knight effectively is
dominated it means it can't make any
progress towards this side of the board
so this is what I had in mind this is
the shape I had in my head and I knew
this Bishop had to go here so it's like
it's like that kids song right I mean
you want to move the pawn but the
bishops in the way now you want to move
the bishop but the Queen is in the way
so it's like a chain daga domino effect
so now we got to move the Queen and we
got to find a good square for the Queen
so ideally I would like to put my queen
on d7 that way I could put my bishop on
d8 and that way I could put my pawn on
g5 so the idea is taking shape but
unfortunately after Queen d7 White has
Knight b6 so
the real question here is how do I stop
Knight b6 so that I can play Queen d7
yeah so I just played rook b8 weight
went Queen d3
I went Queen d7 rook d1 and now I went a
5 first the only reason I didn't play
Bishop d8 quite yet I think was because
I might have been concerned with night
before and this pawn on d6 become weak
so after night before White has set up
the battery that I was talking about
before on the D file and I think if I go
a 5 y can just take and after we trade
everything on the D file if I just take
on before white just takes on e6 and I
haven't really accomplished much
so here this bishops still in chief oh
yeah so here I played a five first and
the rook is actually doing a really good
job on b8 because not only stopping
Knight b6 but it defended my pawn on b5
so that I could play a five so this
whole game is really going to start
revolving around dominating this night
and by dominating I always mean
restricting so I'm taking squares away
from this night I took a square away
when I played f4 because it can't go to
e3 I'm taking another square away now
when I play a five because then I can't
go to before and I also did it when I
played rook b8 because then I couldn't
go to b6 so after a three Bishop d8 and
now things are taking color blacks
position I think is starting to look
very coherent and there's a nice flow to
it because I have my bishops on good
squares where they're not in the way but
they're also active so I don't have to
actually worry about the weakness on the
pond e6 because I'm using White's pieces
against white I'm using this night as my
best protector of d6 as long as this
night stays on d5 I don't have to worry
about defending this pawn so after
Bishop b3 I just went out with my idea
grouchy eight so this is why I didn't
want to keep my Bishop on h4 or our
nature six because now I'm planning to
play aged five and g4 you know to kind
of anticipating my idea so what white is
preparing is that if I play h5 and g4
he's just gonna take with the H pawn and
open up the H file and it's actually my
king that's going to be in trouble so
what I decided here was that I needed to
find a good place for my king because
yes this this is my idea this is what I
want to do but I don't want to do it
with my King on h8 because my king is
going to become very vulnerable there so
how do we how do we fix this King Pro
home and it's going to be a similar type
of retrograde analysis I guess that we
did with rook b8
it's kind of a same idea that white
play-doh I just moved the King tap to
and I know I want to get my king out of
h8 yeah I mean this is where I would
want my king but something looks odd
about a move like King g7 to me and it
has to do with me wanting to play g4 and
if I want to play g4 I want my rook to
be behind the pawn and I don't want to
be anything in the middle so I don't
want to put the king in front of the
rook but I didn't want making to go to
g7 so that should give us some clues
yeah exactly
so the idea of rook g6 is just to play
King g7 and not be obstructing the way
of the rook so now after I I do play
King g7 I'm ready to just continue with
h5 and g4 so rook h1 King G 781 h5
it should be one so white is really
trying to do everything he can to stop G
for he put the rook on the H file that
way against G for this work is gonna be
in a nice file put the bishop on d1
because if I rush things now for example
if I play g4 which would be I think a
bad move here after all of the trading
here your Bishop takes Bishop takes
Queen takes I might have jumped the gun
and inadvertently made some bad trades
here because what we've ended up with is
a really good night that really has no
peace that can dislodge it from d5 I
mean that light square bishop was the
only thing I had questioning the
dominance of this knight on d5 against
the bad bishop this bishop I mean it was
good when we had the bishop pair because
the job of this bishop was to make sure
this night couldn't jump anywhere but we
also had the other bishop that was
making sure that if things got too out
of control I could always take down this
Knight here with a move say like Queen
age three if I'm forced to trade Queens
this endgame is gonna be incredibly
unpleasant to play with black just
because this Knight is so strong so
so after Bishop d1 I need to be careful
not to trade the wrong pieces so I want
Queen c8 I'm just trying to find a
better square for my queen since I don't
want to play g4 and get my Queens a g4
allowing this night to stay unchallenged
I figured well another way I can improve
this queen is to get it to c5 which
looks like an active square I could have
also played Queen a7 with check which
would have probably been a little bit
better just because I don't need the
Queen to be on c5 it does the same thing
from a7 we have seven the idea take this
guy might work the the only difference
here is that if we get a position let's
let's say it's blacks move again if if
black takes on the five Queen takes we
trade everything and we get this
position I've moved my pawns too much
now and I'm leaving some weaknesses
behind
for example this bishop could easily
reroute to c2 and have a pretty decent
square on e4 so it is true that this is
not the ideal scenario for white but
it's also not ideal for black either I
mean if the pawn was here then you would
be absolutely right because the the goal
of these pawns is no longer to start an
attack but rather just to limit the
scope of whites pieces here you're doing
the exact opposite now you're just
clearing the way for the bishop to land
on a very nice square like 1/4 so
it's a good question though because it's
you know kind of surprising that this
would make such a big difference and the
kind of piece trades you'd be
considering but yeah already if if I'm
thinking about any trades it would have
to be like some right I would have to be
getting a really sweet deal like it like
it like it went in exchange or something
otherwise my goal is just to prepare G
for and go for an all-out attack so I
play queen c8 Queen e7 was probably
little bit better f1 and now I played
this move it rogue aged six which looks
a little bit strange because I went
through all this trouble to get on the G
file but since white defended pretty
well what I want to do is make sure that
when I do open up the H file that black
I mean that white doesn't get too much
play perhaps with something like f takes
H takes and takes and then swings over
the Queen age three and I get made it on
a chain or something like that like if I
you guys some kind of thing like this
where you know we we do all these bad
trades that we just looked at and all of
a sudden I'm getting mated so I realized
I had enough time to maybe go on doing
some more maneuvers and improve the
position of my pieces so I played rook
h6 with a very specific idea in mind and
I want to get to that in a second so
sorry I played and white when Bishop e2
there we go sorry
so after Queen c5 King f1 now rogue h6
before Queen a 7c4 takes takes green
eggs and now g4 and here we're getting
the position I want to look at so we
trade on the H file now what's a good
move for black here to avoid all this
King takes and you know possible
problems along the H file yeah so this
really throws a wrench in the gears for
white obviously the immediate threat is
just as far away Queen just going to f2
and checkmate
so alright right there yeah there's no
work takes bishop just because of queen
f2 but actually the problem is not how
to defend this rook is it's not really
obvious how are you gonna stop this
check me there's no there's no really
good way of blocking the actions of the
Queen so after g3 actually checkmate is
inevitable so
white 193 I guess setting up one last
trick here at first you might think well
just Bishop takes Queen because well it
wins the Queen and if Knight takes Queen
then again checkmate
but is Bishop takes me a good move here
yeah but I mean still that seems like a
pretty good deal Bishop for Queen and
besides if Bishop takes maybe I can just
take this wrong I mean that might be the
best option that White has I don't know
but is there something better here for
black
that's what I did and what about what
happens after rook g6 check
penis
and here queen takes
yeah and if King aged seven this might
be a little bit unpleasant yeah so we go
back and we get the same position is
there something better we know what King
f7 is no good and h7 is only a draw okay
so now if Queen takes it's not with
check so you have enough time to play
checkmate so white played rook check
what about now yeah obviously if King
takes then we had the same problem with
Queen takes check so King takes
I mean Bishop takes and wait took here
and after King takes Bishop c4 but
unfortunately after the King moves white
does stop the checkmate and takes my
queen but he's down a whole rook so in
this position you just resigned so I
thought we'd combine a couple of things
that I wanted to talk about today I want
to talk about openings which was a big
part of I guess my chest career when I
was trying to become a professional
because you know ever the age of
computers I think has been pretty much
defined by young people studying
openings all the time and I think it did
me a great disservice for a long time
until I learned to incorporate it into
just like studying chess and not
necessarily studying opening